inicia la gira del presidente francés
emmanuel macrón en áfrica central su
primera parada
camerún la finalidad del viaje reforzar
los lazos políticos con el continente y
ayudar a impulsar la producción agrícola
en medio de la creciente inseguridad
alimentaria vinculada con la guerra en
ucrania
a todos nos atacan diciendo que las
sanciones europeas son la causa de la
crisis alimentaria son mentiras
absolutas totalmente falsas los
alimentos y la energía- se han
convertido en el arma de guerra de rusia
pero todos tenemos que enfrentar
nuestras responsabilidades debemos
ayudar al continente africano a producir
más para sí mismo y la agenda para el
desarrollo agrícola sostenible y la
reforestación es clave muchas naciones
africanas se enfrentan a problemas de
seguridad alimentaria y energética
debido a su dependencia del grano
ucraniano y la energía rusa los
gobiernos africanos han evitado tomar
partido y se han negado a sumarse a las
condenas y sanciones occidentales por el
comportamiento de rusia en ucrania pero
el sentimiento antifrancés está
aumentando en las antiguas colonias
francés de áfrica occidental haciendo
que la opinión se incline a favor de
rusia
salió de la relación
en cuanto a las relaciones con rusia se
remontan a mucho tiempo atrás y hemos
firmado un acuerdo de cooperación con
este país que ha expirado y que hemos
renovado
la expiración
el viaje de mi ministro a rusia no tiene
ninguna relación con la situación de
guerra en ucrania
macrón buscará recuperar los lazos
políticos y económicos de francia en el
continente continuará su visita por
áfrica el miércoles en benin y en guinea
bissau en cuevas